Citizen movement
is very different from the old policy.
The main discourse of the citizen movement
is that they
represent youth and the new politics,
which are very different from traditional matches.
But the reality is that many of its politicians
most important
spent years in other matches,
many were trained in the PRI,
bread,
PRD or Morena.
The National Coordinator and founder of the movement
citizen is Dante Delgado,
who spent decades in the PRI,
his political mentor,
in fact,
he was one of the PRI members
most gloomy of all time,
Fernando Gutierrez neighborhoods,
Dante,
left the PRI to found convergence,
who later became an MC.
Enrique Alfaro,
current governor of Jalisco,
is another of the most important semiecistas,
but in the past he represented the PRI and then the PRD.
Solomon Chertorivsky probably
will be the MC candidate
he head of government of the capital in 2024.
During the six-year term of Felipe Calderón.
He was general director of diconza and later
secretary of health.
He was also secretary of development
of the capital city.
In the government of PRD member Miguel Ángel Mancera.
In 2019,
Ivonne wanted to be president of the PRI,
but lost.
He resigned from the PRI after 29 years of membership.
Today she is a deputy with MC.
Amalia Garcia.
He was a founding member of the PRD.
20 years ago
won the governorship of Zacatecas with that party.
She is now an MC deputy.
José Luis Pech.
He had positions in PRI governments,
then moved on to Morena.
Last year
left Morena
to Search for the Governorship of Quintana Roo
with citizen movement and is now a senator with MC
and so we could go on for a while
breaking down the careers of deputies,
senators and emesist mayors.
In fact,
by the end of this year MC had 28 deputies,
of those
28 12 represented or were affiliated with the PRI,
Pan,
PRD or Morena.
It also had 13 senators,
of those 13
10 represented or were affiliated with the PRI,
Pan,
PRD or Morena.
Yes,
some of the figures most visible to the outside world
are politicians
young people who have not been to other parties,
but inside
movement
citizen is full of veteran officials
that were part of the old policy